i am going to try using the t
results so what should be my first line
tan x on two kind of an important line
okay
it's even more important than you think
it is all right so that's the case i'm
going to go straight into my
substitution now
okay this is going to be 2t
this is going to be 1 minus t squared
that's equal to 1. by the way just a
quick note it is absolutely critical
even though you're going to start to get
a little more comfortable with this you
should never never never ever
write the first line with your one plus
t squared on this side you're like oh of
course i want to multiply through
right you will always multiply through
but you're not doing the substitution
okay you're not showing that i know what
the t results are for sine and cosine
so this line is critical okay after you
have that line
knock yourself out right which is
exactly what we're going to do
i got my 2t minus 1 plus t squared
yep one plus t squared
there so far so good okay so you start
to think okay i'm going to cancel some
things here i've got t squared on both
sides
now normally i would move everything
over to the left hand side but because i
don't have any more t
squareds i'm going to leave that 2t
on the left hand side by itself and move
this guy
over that side leaving me with a 2. so
far so good
yeah so t is equal to 1 but remember
t is in fact tan of x on 2.
so remember there is some angle that
when you take 10 of that
you'll get 1. tan of 45 degrees
x on 2 equals 45. just like before
i'm in this domain when i'm solving
functions of
in terms of x on 2. so normally if i saw
10 of something equals 1 i would
normally say there's one solution
and then i'll get my next one 180
degrees later at 225
but i'm not in that domain because i'm
in terms of x on two
so that's it okay so then i say x equals
90
and then raise my eyebrow
now what's going on okay something's
gone wrong and there's a few ways to
know okay
for starters like i showed you a
question before right they're looking
almost exactly like this i just slightly
adjusted the coefficients
okay now i didn't adjust them that much
we got two solutions before
i ought to kind of expect two solutions
here right
there's something else that's a bit sus
right we started with a quadratic things
were fine
but then the quadratic just kind of
disappeared
right that's why we went from two
solutions
to one okay now you can be doubly sure
because
this guy appeared right um remember i
always encourage you as much as possible
to think
terms in terms of visuals right so
solving this
do you agree is saying like this is a
graph
sine x minus cos x it's a graph and it's
going to go like that
and when's it equal to one right now
it's a bit hard to picture because you
guys haven't done many graphs like this
you will
right so let me give you one that would
be a little bit easier to visualize
see this guy i'm going to kick him over
the other side
do you agree that our original question
and this red line this red equation they
should have the same equations right the
same
solutions rather make sense now these
this is really easy to visualize we all
know what this looks like
okay let's do sine that's nice and easy
there's sine what's the range of sine
one
to one minus one to one
mathematicians read things in ascending
order okay
i've got one plus cos x on the right
hand side what's the
range of one plus cos x
zero it's it's this range moved up
plus one so it's not a two isn't it so
if there's there's not
and here's two so it's just the regular
old cosine thing
but it's it's all been raised up okay so
i'm getting this kind of shape
i missed you get the idea okay now sure
enough
as we kind of were anticipating there's
one solution
surprise surprise 90 degrees and then
there's another solution
right there
what's that angle that's 180
180 180 sine of 180 is equal to
zero zero
zero cos of 180 is equal to negative one
so
minus negative one is one
180 is a solution so why did
it disappear
okay all right remember i said what's
the first line right and i made a big
deal out of it and some of you are like
oh whoops i forgot to write the first
line
the first line is critical but this is
not the first line
that's not what the first slide should
be because 10
picture tan picture it in your head
right from
north to 360. what's it look like well
it's got a couple of these guys hanging
around doesn't it
right and then it looks like this
and this see it okay
so where does it exist and where does it
not exist
okay i can see it has asymptotes at x
equals
90 and x equals to 70.
see right so x
can't be equal to 90 really like it
doesn't work you put it into 10 it just
blows up
that's 10x but i'm dealing with tan off
exon two
right so in fact if i put in
not 90 right but if i put in
180 degrees what happens here tan of 180
on 2
is 1090 it explodes there's no solution
there
right this thing will not have solutions
at 180 degrees right but that's
completely foreign to the question
we introduced this to you business right
this question
has no tens in it it shouldn't have this
problem
right and sure enough when we graphed it
it didn't it has a solution at those
points
okay so here's what we're missing and
this is what your four lines before and
we'll put it on both of these okay
you arrive at the end right if you use
t results if you use t results you must
every single time
check if this is a solution right
because you've artificially removed it
from the question
right so you have to say test
x equals a hundred and eighty degrees
right yeah um
the does not come up because t formulas
which make from the right angle
okay another way to make sense of it
right yeah things things break down
because we've introduced this extra
structure which makes it easier to solve
but in the process it removes things
okay so i'm going to test it here's the
way i do it i'd say
left hand side equals and then i'm
literally going to put the numbers in
right
i'm going to go sine and y we did this
about two minutes ago
minus cos of 180 okay
sine 180 is not minus
cos of 180 is negative one
and sure enough that's one which is the
right hand
side so therefore 180 degrees is a
solution it satisfies the original
question yeah
okay so the answer is yes because you
know
10 is periodic however because of the
domain you're actually interested in
in practice this is really all you're
ever gonna have to worry about okay
um so so yeah but that's worth 94.
x equals 180 that's a solution so
therefore
x is equal to 90 degrees or 180.
okay so this is kind of like the
achilles heel
of the t results for this okay you will
notice it by the way
it should do this you shouldn't just be
blindly always testing it
right there will be things that cancel
and you'll be like what happened to my
other solution
it just sort of disappeared right now
even if that doesn't happen which is
what happened here we've got two
solutions and that's actually correct
right you still have to test right you
still have to show this so this is what
those four lines are for
you'd say test x equals 180 degrees
right now the question we started with
was
what was the three side x yeah three
sine
180 degrees minus two cos
180 degrees okay this is not hard to
evaluate it doesn't
it's not like oh man the t result sucks
they add all this extra work this part
here
is trivial the hardest part is just
remembering to do it okay
sine 180 we already said that zero
that's minus two cos 180 we already said
that was minus one
so you get two which is not equal to the
right hand side so no problems
180 is not a solution and we've already
found the two they're there
okay
yes okay so if you are given a question
and t results are the only way
excuse me um to solve it which is
uncommon but admittedly
um then there will be a mark diverted to
that um for a question like this
i wouldn't be surprised if it was or if
it was this question
it'll be three marks maybe three months
um the
first mark would be on actually doing
the substitution and getting the right
algebra there
second mark would be for the solution
third mark would be for the test
which gets you the other solution right
here again
three marks your first two marks will be
to get to these solutions through the
algebra and your last mark is for
testing
and showing that x equals 180 isn't done
okay